I would say like if there's been one big
motivator for wanting to learn more
Japanese now is now having people come
in and being like oh you got to be then
the hunger Josie person now because
um same thing happened to me actually
where where we have we had this uh we
they were looking for a place to eat you
know beforehand and it's hard to find a
place for 12 people 12 yeah 12. there's
12 years yeah there was 12 of us right I
would have I literally told a bunch of
people I was like can we split this up
like yeah this is not happening like
we're not getting in anywhere we have
two unless you don't book ahead of time
yeah no no no no you did one day advance
yeah yeah so that's that's the thing
that's why I chose um I forgot the I I
forgot the name of the place but the
yakaniki place I chose was a brand you
know it was a chain
it's uh
there's only a few cue
not not until Julian right I'm not
George you're in I I forgot what it was
but I remember phoning up
I remember finding one of the branches
and I was phoning up and asking if they
had space for 12.
um and they did you know it was it was
it was all good you know I was like no
way as they did yeah yeah they did they
did I was like I was like confidently I
I can I can [ __ ] do this all of my
years in Japan have built up to this
moment I can do this I like it's I've
I've booked tables before I've like I'm
very satisfying yeah yeah very satisfied
booking tables
um I kind of know the script and I kind
of know how to go off scripted just in
case so I asked if they have space for
12. they go great I ask if we can split
into tables just in case because it's a
big group and they're like that's that's
no problem at all
um I asked for the time I asked for 6 30
and uh they said they don't have a space
for 6 30. uh can you do space at 8 30
and I'm like sure that's okay
um and then they said something that I
didn't understand and I was like [ __ ] I
was like what's important [ __ ] I was
doing doing so well and you know you
know how you know how when how does the
game of Pluto began and thus thus the
Sherlock game begins right so your kids
here's here's what it's like being not
exactly you know learning a language and
knowing some words for not knowing the
entire context of what's being said you
recognize some words and within that you
try to infer what they're trying to say
now normally this is much easier when
you're in person because you've got you
know body language you've got hand
signals you've got more context clues
it's ten times harder on the phone right
uh because you've got you got nothing
but just you know your listening skills
and so what I heard was I heard uh can I
confirm and I and uh and she said which
one and then something I was like [ __ ]
what is what is she trying to confirm
with me and I was just like I remember
browsing through their menu and I was
and they had like different tiers for
whichever menu you wanted this or you
need to be yeah so I was like great it
must be that one and I was like can I
have the menu That's the middles the
middle uh the middle menu please
and she was like and [ __ ] I heard a PO I
heard a pause
and I was like oh no
oh no I was like I have chosen the wrong
dialogue I'm correct I have chosen the
wrong dialogue option [ __ ] and she was
like uh no no I and she she tries and
then here's where like goes here's like
if I'd chosen the right dialogue option
it's like great [ __ ] great genius no
hunger josu hello yeah I choose the
wrong dialogue option I've opened up
another dialogue tree with even more
complex dialogue options and I've just
gotten myself into a [ __ ] mess you've
opened up the explanation
you found the Elden ring boss
basically so she says uh no no no no
um just uh and and then she she starts
going into even more complex like goes
into detail it goes into detail about it
and I just like I understand even less
and so my Panic brain just goes yes
in English no no I I go hey you should
have started with the high yeah yeah
that's just like my default that's
everyone's defense that's my default
dialogue and that works I would say 80
it works a shocking amount yeah this was
one of the times where it didn't work
and she was like uh
[Music]
goes off away for a minute and I'm like
oh [ __ ] what did I just say yes to what
did I just say yes to like would you
like to buy shares in our company
so you want to get a mortgage yeah
and so she goes off for five for five
minutes and then she comes back and she
oh she starts like spewing me the entire
[ __ ] gospel she starts speaking to me
like the entire Holy Bible and then she
ends is that okay and I'm like no yes
and then and then and then and then she
was just like okay so just to confirm
you just agree to all of these things
can I can I put you down and I'm like
yes and then and then she goes and then
I'm gonna go and then I go and then she
goes great
hangs up the phone the first thing I
immediately do is uh hit up our intern
Kai and just be like Kai can you find up
this place and just confirm that I
actually made a [ __ ] booking
and then I find out what she was trying
to confirm with me was I thought by
phoning this specific number yeah that
it would go straight to the restaurant
right but because it was a branch she
was trying to confirm which branch
which I've I've never been asked I've
never heard that before I've never been
on this one weird as [ __ ] yeah I've
never been asked that question before
you phone up like the company or like I
don't know I I don't know I just phoned
up the uh because normally if you go on
Google Maps and you yeah yeah the
location and the number is specifically
for the building yeah yeah yeah exactly
so yeah I've never heard of that before
yeah
I was just like guys I think I [ __ ] up
but I don't want to look bad in front of
my friends uh can you guys save me
please he's like do you guys sleep
that's why I like it when the Google
Maps has the reservation option in Japan
that's oh yeah no no like it like this
Branch had a reservation option but not
for more than six people which is why
which is why like I knew this one phone
call was gonna push my language ability
level yeah to to its limit at the time
and you know I was doing I was doing so
well I was this close I was this close
yeah
stall I've never heard of that that's
like doing a boss battle and then you
think you've beaten them and then the
phase two starts yeah
see I I'm like kind of in a sense I'm
kind of jealous though because I haven't
experienced that yet because I'm not I'm
I'm not good nor bad enough at a current
language where I can try to attempt to
do certain things yeah it's either I
know the language or I know nothing
about the language yeah so I want to get
to a point where I'm kind of like in the
Middle where you guys are where it's
like you're on the cusp of going from
I'm learning the language to I can speak
it conversationally yeah so it's like I
don't know I've always wanted to learn a
third language I mean I mean I've got
like the Joey experience once in my life
where I was able to like yeah
yeah when we're in LA and we went to the
Thai restaurant and I think it was like
the first ever time I've been to a Thai
restaurant with these boys because you
never you're like every time
[ __ ] there's got to be some good
Thai food here no but yeah Thai food in
L.A really good uh because they have
like actual so many more options than
you can find in restaurants in like the
UK and stuff and so I was like great you
know able to like ask you know Flex My
Thai you know asking you know give give
us a good stuff just give us a good
question that's the most I've ever heard
you speaking tonight yeah yeah but I I
didn't know what you were saying but I
would just like to imagine that you were
like bring me the real menu not this
[ __ ] right here I know you have it
somewhere back there
basically all the only thing I was
asking was yes I was asking for things
that actually not on the menu and they I
was asking if they have it they said yes
I was like oh give me give me like give
me like your menu give me like the Thai
Spice don't don't give me like the baby
foreign
[Laughter]